PROFESSOR: This is Louis--
L-O-U-I-S d-e Broglie.
And this is not
hyphenated nor together.
They are separate.
And the d is not
capitalized apparently too.
And it's 1924, the photon
as a particle is clear,
and the photon is also a wave.
And Louis de Broglie
basically had a great insight
in which he said that
if this is supposed
to be a universal or a real
basic physical property
that photons are
waves and particles,
we knew them as waves and now
we know they're particles.
But if they are dualed
with respect to each other,
both descriptions are
in different regimes
and in a sense, a particle
at the end of the day
has wave attributes and
particle attributes.
Wave attributes
because it interferes
and is described by waves.
And particle attributes is
because it has a definite
amount of energy,
it comes in packets,
they cannot be broken
into other things--
this could be a more
general property.
And in a sense, you could
say that de Broglie did
a fundamental step almost
as important as Schrodinger
when he claimed that all matter
particles behave as waves as
well.
Not just the photon, that's one
example, but everybody does.
So associated to every modern
particle, there is a wave.
But that is quite interesting
because in quantum mechanics,
you have the photon
and it's a particle,
but it's associated to a wave
and if you are a little quick,
you say, oh sure, the
electromagnetic wave,
but no, in quantum
mechanics, it's
the probability amplitude
to be some work.
Those are the numbers
we tracked in the mass
and the interferometer, the
probability to be sampled.
We didn't track the
waves or a single photon,
the wave was a wave of
probability amplitude,
something they didn't know at
all about yet at that time.
So de Broglie's says just like
the photons have properties
of particles and
properties of waves,
every particle has
properties of waves as well
and every wave has a
property of particles.
But what is left unsaid here
is yes, you have a wave,
but a wave of what?
And we've already
told you a little bit,
the answer has to do
with probability waves.
So it's very strange that
the fundamental equation
for a wave that represents
a particle is not
an electric field or
a sound wave or this,
it's for all of them
is a probability wave.
Very, very surprising.
But that's what de
Broglie's ideas led to.
So if you had a photon, you
would say it's a particle,
and when you think
of it as a particle,
you would say it's a bundle of
some energy and some momentum.
And if you think
of it as a wave,
you would say it
has a frequency.
And that's a particle wave
duality or in some sense,
a particle wave
description of this
object-- you have a particle
and a wave at the same time.
When we have this, we have
a particle wave duality.
And de Broglie said that this
is universal for all particles.
Universal.
And it appeared the
name of matter waves.
These are the matter waves that
we're going to try to discuss.
These are the waves
of something that
are probability amplitudes
we're going to try to discuss.
So you could say wave of what?
What.
And that comes
later, but the answer
is probability amplitudes, those
complex numbers whose squares
are probabilities.
So just like we
had for a photon,
de Broglie's idea was that we
would associate to a particle
a wave that depends
on the momentum.
So remember, the
Compton wavelength
was a universal--
for any particle,
the Compton wavelength
is just one number,
but just for photons,
the wavelength depends
on the momentum, so
in general, it should
be dependent on the momentum.
So we say that for a
particle of momentum p,
we associate a wave--
a plane wave, in fact--
a plane wave, so we're getting
a little more technical,
with of lambda equals
h over p, which
is the de Broglie wavelength--
de Broglie wavelength.
So it's a pretty
daring statement.
It was his PhD thesis and there
was no experimental evidence
for it.
It was a very
natural conjecture--
we'll discuss it a lot
more next lecture--
but there are very
little evidence for it.
So experiments can
a few years later,
and people saw that you
could interfere or diffract
electrons.
They would behave, colliding
into lattices like waves,
and those are rather
famous experiments
of Davisson and Germer.
So particles, just like you
do as an interference effect--
a two slit interference
effect in which
you have a screen, a slit and
a screen, and you shine photons
and then you get an
interference effect over here
because of the wave
nature of photons,
or in quantum
mechanics, you would
say, because there are
probability amplitudes, that
are complex numbers that
have to be interfered
between the possibilities
of the two paths,
because every photon
goes through both paths
at the same time, these
experiments of interference,
or two slit interference,
were done for electrons.
And then, eventually,
they've been
done for bigger and
bigger particles,
so that it's not just
something that you do
with elementary particles now.
There's experiments done
about three years ago--
I will put on the web site or on
the notes some of these things
so that you can
see them, but now
you can throw in
molecules here, molecules
that have a weight of now 10,000
atomic mass units, like 10,000
protons, like hundreds of--
430 atom molecules, and you can
get an interference pattern,
so it's pretty ridiculous.
It's almost like, you one
day so you throw a baseball
and you're going to see
an interference pattern,
but, you know,
we've got to things
with about 10,000 hydrogen
atoms and de Broglie
wavelengths of 1 picometer,
which are pretty unbelievable.
So the experiments are done
with those particles and in fact
with electrons.
People do those
experiments and they're
in very beautiful
movies in which you
see those electrons hitting
on the screen and then--
I'll give you some links so
you can find them as well--
and you see one
electron falls here
and it gets detected and two
electrons, three electrons,
four electrons, five electrons,
six electrons-- by the time
you get 10,000 electrons,
you see lots of electrons
here, very well here,
lots of electrons
here, and the whole
interference pattern is created
by sending one electron at
that time in an experiment that
takes several hours
and it's reduced
to a movie of about one minute.
So particles, big particles
interfere, not just photons
interfere.
So those particles
have some waves,
some matter waves discovered by
de Broglie, and next lecture,
we're going to track
the story from de
Broglie to the
Schrodinger equation
where the nature of the
wave suddenly becomes clear.